Pew-pew-pew, welcome back to part four of "Detroit: Become Human".
Last episode was oh my geez.
I keep getting comments from you guys saying that I, well I read them now, literally. I published a video now
I need to be nice to Hank. So I'm gonna try to be nicer to Hank. We're neutral right now. So there's a lot of...
way-good ways to get on his good side. Chicken food. That seems great.
You want some chicken food?
Oh, it's chicken feed.
I'm literally recording my third video today. I'm just crunching it out
Like the good old days.
Literally Marzia is away tonight. I have nothing else to do. Ha.
Just feeling like I should let you guys know in case I sound different or if I'm acting like a...
dumb. Not smart.
All right, I'm in. Damn straight! Hey!
You won't regret this!
Can I have hot dog too Hank?
What is your problem? Haha.
Don't you ever do as you're told?
Look, you don't have to follow me around like a poodle! I thought you liked dogs?
All right, we gotta get in his good side. What are we gonna do?
Reconcile.
I think our relationship got off on a wrong foot. We should forget what happened and start over.
What do you say?
Hahaha.
They send me a piece of plastic for a partner and I'm dealing with it. But if you think we're gonna be buddies,
you're stupid as you look. HUH! I don't look stupid.
I like Connor.
Da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da. Let me scan that first, huh.
Hamburger,
carbohydrates, salt, fat, water.
No, no no Hank you got it Hank that is
Sugar, pineapple.. actually sounds good i would love that.
Don't leave that thing here not a chance follows me everywhere
Stop calling me a thing man. Give me some chicken.
Just give me some chicken
I feel like it would be great to have an Android around.
You could... let's talk about gambling. He doesn't want to talk about cholesterol
Oh god. Can I get in on it?
But you're cop
Phew, he just doesn't get it
You got a free meal
So you're corrupt cop, is that it?
He doesn't seem to like that
There must be a.. yeah there must be a reason
Let's talk about the deviants
Ew, he has pickles on his burger? What is wrong with him?
That was not that complicated
Why does he talk about them like they just came to.. from alien
So mean
Yeah, and he almost shot me
why would I lie about that?
Uhh.. sure
And you could use a haircut
Since then I think working with an officer with
Personal issues is an added challenge
But adapting the human unpredictability is one of my futures
Oh, I thought he was winking at him. It's a few blocks away
I'll be in the car
Well played Connor, well played
Radio just stopped out of nowhere
David cage step up your game
literally
Wait what had just happened.
He's so awkward.
I love their interaction, so good.
There's this funny conspiracy about pigeons cuz you never seen a baby pigeon, right, huh?
you never you never seen a small pigeon so the conspiracies by the
Pigeons are created by CIA to spy on us
We need reality they just stay in their nest until they're grown up or at big enough that's why
But I still find it funny
I can tell you more about CIA pigeons, but some action is coming now
This looks so much like heavy rain. I wonder why
I Guess I should go first. I could be the tank, you know
Hey more pidgeons, this is the CIA hideout where they build the pigeons! Whoa3x
My places you cannot have a look at this too much
Rain rains going solo, okay
Oh
It's disgusting you poor console players. Is this the way you have to deal with a
pity
Makes me hate can't eat any food a cancer Wow
truly pathetic
suspect
Okay
That must mean something oh, that's cool I can pass on you know
Fresh air out of my way pigeon
Also, did you know you're not supposed to give pigeon right?
All right ducks, you're not supposed to give ducks right I forgot you know, what don't listen to me
Can we tell who that is, it's led is in the sink
My surprise it was an Android. No human could live with all these fucking pigeons
You see Matt to lick into Telugu blue blood
Why didn't I like it that's the real question
Look there you are again, huh? Nine-year-olds, huh? Interesting
Any idea whatever may come I never seen nine-year-olds and you at the same time written
2471 times it's the same sign Ortiz's Android wrote on the shower wall
Why are they obsessed with this sign
Looks like mazes or something
It's like a math maybe
Obsessive-compulsive, right
What is it me
Me keep flipping over chairs. Like I don't like it. I just don't like I don't have to be okay with it. I
Wouldn't still thank you game I could not I figure that out myself
Scan the chair. That's right
It will say wooden chair just in case just in case i'm david cage and make video games but they're like movies where
Is it David
It's a chair, where is a
Saint
Oh my god
Okay find cause of loud noise, maybe the birds
Military jacket, okay Artie, it would make sense for the military to use androids
Anything right, that's something your mom does when you're in first grade
Rupert Travis or driver's license is fake cool. At least we didn't come from
But we have found the noise
You have to find the other one for some reason
Alexa
We're
These are so lame where Oh,
Recycled paper reasonably moved. Okay. What's the conclusion? Oh
Okay, all right I get it
That's the thing on the window
I
don't know it looks like a notebook, but it's
Indecipherable I
Guess who keeps? Oh my god. The birds are so annoying. I guess if you have to keep finding the other
Let's just go up and down
Oh
Hey, hey, hey, I don't need you judge me. I don't need your judgment. I'm sure you get suck in games
Sometimes - okay. Don't judge me, please
Suspect was here recently
Hey, he found what an idiot
He ran to the living room after being traumatized by the chair
All right, well, why don't we check out what he was trying to do rather on the wall, I guess he was doing the spreadsheets
And then he plopped over the pigeon thing that made the noise probably then
Substantial damage on the pigeon cage. It's got fingerprints. Oh
it's fecal matter yucky ducky, but
Medal all right. Let's see what happened. I can't wait
But I want to know is why all the pigeons live there
CIA that's right. That's right everybody you
Never seen a baby pigeon so why is that CIA wants to spy on us?
They're robots
To be fair like with all the weeds
Expect documents. I think they have to be public after certain amount of years. There's there's experiments of CIA trying to put
Microphones on cats
And they use the tail to put like the antenna is awful
And the thing was they were completely useless because the cat just wouldn't go where they wanted them to go
whoa
That's not a pigeon are you crazy it's a chase scene everybody. All right, let's make sure we get this
For sure we hit up
Whoa, that's cool
O'Connor my man. All right. What now? Oh I just this
Is all Sun
Yes
Fast but risky. Oh, yeah
We going fast boys save you do the bad fest but risk, yeah, I
Need it fast give it to me fares
directly back
directed but crown
Bring it on
I'm kinda ah
Ain't nothin a teacher
Slide it jump. Yeah
Alexa this is epic
Go get her you did the slide move. I haven't done that sand
Ever I never done that I really want to do this like flowers
Okay directly, it's a fast but risk, what are you thinking huh? Woody?
I was born for this and lived with this I breathed this
They made a quick time a lot easier, I remember they were quite tricky and every or maybe I'm just a really good epic gamer
You see I can't fail I'm too strong and too strong I'm too powerful I will never say hey who you calling me answer
Come on direct but crowded let's go, baby
Be quiet Lex I meant I meant that whoo
Where you going cuz where you going, huh, get out of my way son
Dissolving corn everybody
I
Can't we we gotta save Hank your doofus your dingus
No, I had it
We're friends now
Nothin thank you I'll take it. You know what I'll take it
I've been playing pug G randoms lately
Just cuz people I do get recognized sometimes but most of the times people have no idea who I am, which is really nice
It sounds so pathetic but like
Everyone always Know Who I am anytime I hang out and just some which I don't mind but like
Sometimes it's nice to just talk to someone with no clue who you are
You know what? I mean?
Sounds are like intervenor. That's not what I mean. It's more like
Sorry, it feels liberating. Who are you?
fugitives
Just like you and I've been really enjoying it especially if I make a friend and they don't know who I am
I'm like
Okay
Nineteen of us still in working order
The rest were damaged escaping their masters many tried to reach Jericho
Few succeed humans have little pity for our kind
This is Jericho, it's a refuge for those who don't want to be slaves anymore. You all have the thing in your dingus
Then you knew that only an Android could follow the trail didn't you okay now the graffiti makes sense like now I feel bad
If you could decide for the signs because one of us trusted you enough to give you the key. I
Understand how you feel, but we have more freedom here than you ever did. I
Came to Jericho looking for hope
You guys are just a bunch of crackheads here
Mmm, you're lost. Oh, it's handling. The rest of us. You just hit me. We didn't ask for this
All we can do now is deal with
The Ainu does it right away you're safe here you can stay with us as long as you want
Go and see Lucy she might be able to help you
Do
Saddle it No, thank you. Mrs. Dumpling smells, too
disgusting
Crackheads sitting around doing nothing
Pathetic lowlife piece of garbage. I don't like it. Are you losing?
More like are you Lucy loser?
Yeah
Sit down
Not decimas it now it does meseta
Show me my
Oh she can repair it I'll stop the bleeding
This snot is proceeding
Drink this
It's a monster energy drinks mixed with gvo you learn police powers unknown
You will be more powerful than you ever imagined
Hey Amy to sculpt a
That in a gulp, I don't know go piss
Give me your hand why?
Okay, this is not how you handle
And you lost it oh, yeah
You've seen hell and now he'll lives in you
Your heart is troubled a part of shadow and a part of light
Which will prevail
Your choices will shape our destiny
You know how Hank said when he talked
Sorry, when Hank spoke to Connor before at the at the food place. He mentioned that
We don't they don't actually have emotions. They just have simulated emotions
So they're not real but for humans our emotions are completely
Technically simulated as well. There's really no difference about it everyone
Well, not everyone but a lot of people see love for example as this mystic
unexplainable thing when really it's just chemicals in our brain and you can very easily be
Explained and also
It's not just a thing for humans
It's not like it's this impossible thing. It's a nice thing way to look at it though. I get it
Let's just say for 20 Hellyeah
Diagnostic program isn't working
I don't think it would have anything good to say anyway, what happened here?
He's got robots no, what no, what if they wanted to have fun I
Don't want to shut down
I don't wanna sit down
All right, she wanted live
All right, we just got to keep exploring
He said I bear all lit it on fire stupid peril
Remember the barrel means
Hit a lot of times I look back on like old PewDiePie and I just cringe but
It's also wonderful. It's something nice about it
Well, that's probably only before like you before you were born no, I don't time stops
What's your name Marcus
I was glad to meet you Marcus. Oh!!
I guess she got that was dark. I didn't mean to laughter
Yeah, what an awkward timing
Okay, this is pretty great
It's getting really nihilistic I don't like it
Okay
This part is pretty depressing. I think we should we should get out of here. Oh
My god, is that a kid Ike can you get worse?
Here you have time with a dead kid what the hell is this they threw him out when they didn't want him anymore
He was living on the streets before we brought him here
They'll all shut down if we don't find a way to help them to help them
We need blue blood and bio components. We salvage what we can from those who shut down
But there's never enough good thing. I just call it a down a hole
They won't
We're slowly dying out
I can't be bothered letting more bearable. Who are you guys then? Sorry. I stopped looking over here
Okay, do you read really didn't need to tell me that
Cyber light warehousing docks, West Virginia
House a plane
All right, you having fun here oh my god
So creepy, I know where we can find spare parts
Cyber life warehouse is in Detroit Harbor. They have everything we need
The docks are guarded. You can't just walk in there and take what we want
Humans will never let us which is why we won't ask permission. We don't have any weapons
And even if you did none of us knows how to fight we can steal what we need without fighting
We'll just get ourselves killed maybe
But it's better than waiting here to be shut down. I'm with you
All right, you know it's not turtles, but I like it
Come on dude, what are you? Okay? Maybe you can get another shirt now to be Nick
His Phoenix four guys are lame
You know at least one person is sitting with me
No, they're not. Okay. All right, sorry
You know what maybe you know what that was me trying to sympathize with you, I'm sorry, there's no recovery from that
There's a lot of rain in this game, yeah
All right, let's go to the creepiest building where you can find everyone
How we're feeling I'm gonna like this one
Something up boy
Let's go Ali boo-boo. Yeah, I call her Ali boom
Oh
My god
Like Oh who's asking I was told you could help us I
Don't know who told you that you came to the wrong place. I'm sorry. Wait, we really need your help
It's let go we'll negotiate for the child
You go the child states we go welcome to chill a
Pedophile joke everybody keep watching the video
Come on don't be shy okay. This is epic. He's got an ostrich
Luther would you be so kind as to take these ladies coats?
Jesus Christ, oh, don't be afraid of a big friendlier
Luther is just another Android that I helped
He keeps me company in this
big empty old house
Jesus Christ
Luther looks like he could squash Alice into a piece of paper
And I kind of want to see it in a pleaded way
Make yourselves at home
How did you hear about me an Android on the street he said you could help us I
See was an awful painting
It's got you must be working on Andrews
About her
She's human
And
You want to find a safe place
Somewhere you can start a new life I
Hear Canada. It's very lovely at this time of year. Yeah, I'm sure it's not raining landscapes
open spaces clean air and no android' laws a
Great place for a fresh start
Yes tents
That's exactly what we want no, of course
Well, I can help you
But first we have to get rid of your tracker tracker
Yeah, all androids are fitted with a tracking device to locate them at all times
I'll remove yours and then you'll both be safe
Come on follow me
Are we feeling about this game wait for us in the living room? No, she always stays with me
Of course
Right this way everything we need is in the basement
The basement, huh? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah
Yeah, the basement of course, of course who doesn't like a good ol good old basement or where it's so dead. We're so good
me neither alleys
Okay, listen that
We have no choice
We have to trust him
What if he just turns out to be super nice I
Needed somewhere discreet for my machines
Removing trackers is illegal. So I opted for discretion over comfort. I
Hope the little one isn't too scared. No, no, she'll be all right, that's good. What is she looking at?
It's a turtle. I bet you it's a turtle. It's a turtle
What do you say this way, please? What's gonna happen there? What are we online? Oh
My god Alice, I swear to God if you drop my hand one more. Alright, I'm just gonna go just gonna go
Whoa, what is this half-life 2
If you could just bond over there I
Need a drink after this episode
Have you guys ever played a half-life 2 should warn you this could be quite unpleasant such a great way
Such a good game it's so disappointing a half-life that he never came out
Sorry, this reminds me of the beginning, you know
Strange
For some unknown reason
The trackers seemed to start working in deviance. That's why it's so hard to find them. Hey, hey
Actually, there's no reason to remove your tracker let go
People believe what they want
You deviants are so naive
They all come to me expecting me to help them and I just reset them
Keep them for my little experiments
Child lock it up. I'll deal with it later a
Deviant that wants to be a mother
That's that's so sweet
I'm so deluded. Oh
My god this guide you I think it's time. We put you out of your misery
I don't really know how we're gonna get out of this. No, not again. Oh
There must be something happening the dream there must be something I can do it always ends up the same way
Tears and dissolution. It must be something I can do. Believe me
You're better off being raised and feeling nothing
No more pain no
Hope - keep him and shave his stupid face almost at you
You don't hurt a lace only I can hurt Alice
Meet me in the living room
Yeah, how
Okay, sure
It's only other way
Okay, I feel like we don't have a lot of time so uh, yeah
Well, that didn't work oh
My god where
If you've moved
Mmm, come on, come on
What's my damn act
No! I failed...
Ah, I wonder I could have gone it there right
I would have hit there
Damnit oh
well
I've decided that I you know
If I mess up I'm gonna keep it just for the sake of tension
It would be kind of lame if I just go back all the time
Yeah
Sure, I wanna
Okay, that's great
He likes to play this creating monsters
Okay demonetized thank you. Whoa, that's cool. I mean, that's awful yeah
It's not that easy like don't be so mean I didn't even do anything
Hey you have tiny hands
Oh
Shoot I forgot to call my parents today
See what you guys do? I choose gaming over my own family. This is not good
There's a ringabel
America vertigo
Anything I can find
Pastas dinner's ready take it up to you. Yes Luther
Where is the dinner?
Sorry
That's his dinner potato chips nice a matter of culture, I like it. Yeah
Wait is that I think I need to pay attention
I
Want to look around just to make sure
We may be possibly unlock our memory, you know, okay, there's nothing really you
Don't stop feeling so I can get my mind of these yellow back people
Why the still alive? I don't know go think I mean my back
Okay, oh
Wait, this is outdoors. Yeah
Remain with your own, okay
I guess he's upstairs, right? I don't remember what he says. I have no memory. I
Realize I'm extremely tired. It's fun though. It reminds me. Like when I was younger just like crunching at videos really lame
Really takes me back man. I have such a strict schedule when I shoot videos now
like I have my set working hours that I never go outside of
This feels really weird also especially calling this work I guess but just set it down on the table over there
You having fun here, buddy?
It's let go more like slut cow got them
Potato chips
On a silver tray this guy's a legend
No, that's the spaghetti scene again I can
Bring carcass carcass carcass this
Doesn't have any nipples that's lame
Yeah, there it is oh
No
No, I can't oh god no don't give me don't give me a time thing to save a little girl you sick
Bastard, who is the little girl?
remember remember
Okay, okay. Okay. I'm huge. I'm hastin. I'm hating right now. What are you are you it?
Syme best joke ever made everybody. Thank you
Oh, we'd remember him now perfect everyone just smokes that stuff
Okay that helps
I
Hate how it's timed I hate time stuff
Okay, just keep going you got this good good job you just weights the time
On this or something here
Yes, perfect
No
My name is Cara Yosh
Yeah, we probably shouldn't go in there, okay, so we remember her now that's good
This is thing with his game
They always mix so many genres from like horror to thriller to suspense to love. I love it
Love you
babe
Ain't never gonna stop loving you
Okay, I will go use Dunga
What are you doing nameless you were you're in a bathtub? Oh
She's probably in here. Hey, how you doing, buddy?
Detroit residents were disturbed by we don't have time
A lot of small stuff like that seemed to matter in this crazy
Where is she is stressing me out, man?
Here's Alice
Thank God, thank God
Never thought I'd care about this stupid girl
We have to go follow me and don't weed anyways, okay
Oh now we just got to make sure we can escape
Okay, all right
Bring me the child. Yes. I'm finished you go fix a little
Slack go. Of course, they have to give that weird one a Eastern European name
This is a terrible hiding spot
Oh
God I can't take this. Uh, okay
Is in here
Door slam and brown
He's lost
Yeah, this is epic
Oh my god Alexa, this is epic let's go
Oh my god, he has a shoddy
He's got his lights goes out of shaadi. I went over the door. I don't know crazy right front door
Are you kidding me?
No
Ha ha too slow
Hey
That's right. Take a lamp. Huh? Ha ha ha bet. That was a spirit lamp loser
since of lamps
Let's go. Let's go. Oh god. He's Alice you Dunga
Go Alice you
Just go. Oh my god Alexa, this is bad
You
Should you should look after your house
Not this time whoa get out of my way
Okay, this is epic Alexa this is epic
Yeah, nipple girl get him
He became a deviant in just the right time, thank you convenience zombie horde that I thought I burned down
I didn't want to hurt you
And programmed me to obey Him. I know that it's okay when I saw the little one risk our life to save you
It was like opening my eyes of the first time finally I could see
I know you have no reason to trust me after what I did. Oh he's coming with it
I could protect you you
All right
All right, you know yeah, I trusted slight go and you know, it didn't turn out so bad. So yes
I
Feel like that's a perfect ending. I try to make them an hour. It's a little less but I
Think it would be silly to keep going now. That was a really cool story
really really enjoy that
So Luther joins regardless it seems like oh actually never mind. Never mind. I was wrong
Cool that was really fun
another successful
Chapter hope you guys enjoyed another episode. I'm not recruiting anything more today
Thank you guys for all the support, Rob you and
Bye